ich spüre von eurer seite so diesen
impuls sie nicht nachvollziehen kann es
gibt eine gespaltene gesellschaft es
gibt fast die online hetze geht in das
analoge leben und wir können nicht so
tun als wäre das nicht da wir müssen da
regulieren wir müssen da eingreifen
müssen die sozialen netzwerke in die
verantwortung ziehen genau dieses
problem anzugehen
[Musik]
hier kommt die erste von 13 fragen wenn
wir hass im netz bekämpfen wollen müssen
wir dann nicht vielleicht soziale
netzwerke strenger auch gesetzlich
regulieren wenn ihr sagt ja es ist an
der zeit dann würde ich euch bitten
positioniert euch auf der grünen seite
wenn ihr sagt nee das wird noch ganz
andere gefahren dann geht ihr bitte auf
die gelbe seiten und mit vielen dank
jetzt wissen wir wo ihr steht die frage
ist wo steht ihr beleidigungen
beschimpfungen demütigungen bis hin zu
morddrohungen das ist ja leider alltag
im bundesdeutschen internet und auf der
ganzen welt für die betroffenen ist das
natürlich übel für die sowieso aber auch
gift für die diskussionskultur
insgesamt passt muss bekämpft werden
das ist vollkommen selbstverständlich in
einer demokratie die frage ist wie meine
gäste bei 310 fragen sind sich ja
zumindest am anfang relativ uneins die
spannende frage heute wird sein kommen
sie am ende vielleicht doch noch
zusammen zu einer art kompromiss oder
sogar zu einer lösung dazu also später
mehr
jetzt erstmal die frage an euch wo
würdet ihr euch positionieren auf der
grünen seite
ja wir brauchen mehr regulierungen oder
auf der gelben seite lieber nicht wer
weiß was für gefahren da noch lauern
wer weiß vielleicht wird ja auch eure
meinung im laufe dieser folge noch mal
komplett umgedreht schreibt uns einfach
in die kommentare
die regel bei 13 frage so relativ
einfach wenn ihr der gegenseite in einem
punkt zustimmt dann würde ich euch
bitten kommt einen schritt vor also auf
die gegenseite zu und wenn ihr sagt nee
da wird totaler quatsch erzählt dann
bitte einfach einen schritt zurück also
einen schritt entfernt von der
gegenseite mein ziel muss es natürlich
sein am ende alle hier in dieser mitte
in diesem kompromiss feld zu versammeln
das klappt manchmal manchmal klappt es
auch gar nicht bin sehr gespannt wie ihr
heute drauf seid
wir spielen 13 fragen und hier kommt
frage nummer zwei an channel du bist
glaube ich seit meinem zwölften
lebensjahr auf social media aktiv und du
bist ganz klar für eine stärkere
regulierung und zwar aus ganz
persönlichen erfahrungen nämlich welche
was ist ihr widerfahren
also mein teenager jahren ist facebook
noch ganz neu war gab es dann irgendwie
so facebook gruppen in den leute einfach
auch leute aus meiner schule aber auch
schulen übergreifend damals angefangen
haben facebook gruppen zu öffnen die
dann privatbahnen in den ich gar keine
einsicht hatte oder darüber diskutiert
würde
für wie viele kamele können wir den
chanel kaufen oder die waren schon so
bei ist von ihrem ganzen rassistischen
gedankengut dass sie sich dachten alle
türken werden zu hause geschlagen und
haben sich dann überlegt was können wir
machen damit sie als eltern irgendwas
hören und die dann zu hause den stress
bekommt es war so surreal und ich dachte
so was geht ab und ich hatte da gar
keine kontrolle darüber und konnte da
nichts ändern
ich musste das alles ein verschlucken
und konnte gegen niemanden etwas angehen
weil die auch teilweise alle falschen
namen benutzt haben da drin so dass man
das auch gar nicht rückverfolgen konnte
wer war diese person die mich da jetzt
angegriffen hat oder sonstiges mir ist
persönlich wichtig heute dabei zu sein
weil ich tagtäglich mit hass im internet
zu tun habe und ich habe das einfach
nicht möchte ich möchte auch nicht dass
andere leute das erfahren und durchleben
müssen und deswegen möchte ich meinen
standpunkt und meine meinung der über
teilen das vielleicht andere leute auch
mal checken dass wir das alles
regulieren sollten wie ist es heute
heute ist es eigentlich relativ okay
aber ich habe jetzt zum beispiel so eine
harmonie challenge gestartet das heißt
ich habe meine körperbehaarung wachsen
lassen das hat so viele leute getriggert
oa ich bekommen morddrohungen
die heftigste nachricht dies ist auch so
in meinem kopf drin da die diva datentyp
geschrieben wenn ich dein typ wäre würde
ich die schlafmittel einflößt und deinen
ganzen körper mit enthaarungscreme
eincremen und das war einfach total
übergriffe ich war ja schon fast eine
vergewaltigungs androhung und du glaubst
dass eine stärkere gesetzliche
regulierung das leben einfacher machen
in dieser hass welt nicht für die hasser
für mich definitiv weil wenn ich bin der
auffassung wenn irgendwie klar namen
hinterlegt werden müssen nicht dass ich
den von dir dann einsehen kann sondern
dass diese medien oder die sozialen
medien
das so regeln dass die laster haben so
dass die strafverfolgung einfacher wird
für polizei und instanzen dass die dann
schneller auf diese person kommen können
und die anzeigen auch nicht
unbekannt gestellt werden das ist ja
auch aus charles sich total
nachvollziehbar oder - also die
erfahrung sind natürlich total
unterirdisch und total daneben
und die sind auch jetzt durch nichts zu
relativieren was das zeigt ist wir haben
hass in der gesellschaft das ist ein
problem und wir haben eine gesellschaft
in sozialen netzen wie facebook oder
instagram oder twitter
und das ist ein zweites in meinen augen
separates problemen unsere öffentliche
debatte ist in sozialen netzwerken
ohnehin ständig gut aufgehoben weil wir
da den finanziellen interessen der
anbieterin unterliegen da jetzt noch
gesetzlich einzugreifen wird der
öffentlichen debatte es recht nicht
zuträglich sein und uns einfach nur noch
mehr schaden langfristig müssen wir
einfach von diesen plattformen weg als
ich zur schule gegangen bin war noch
nicht so viele der jugendlichen auf
sozialen netzen
wir haben wir trotzdem mobbing gehabt
noch und nöcher wurden menschen von der
schule runter geekelt das hat sich
abgespielt auf dem schulhof der wehr ein
einflussbereich gewesen für die schule
da ist trotzdem nichts passiert und ich
glaube wir brauchen einfach
gesellschaftlich einen ganz anderen
umgang mit diesen hass reaktionen die
eigentlich immer von relativ armen
würstchen kommen die nicht ertragen
können dass gerade im powerman
stattfindet von leuten die sie sonst
fertig machen und unter drucken konnten
und ich glaube dass wir gerade gewinnen
gegen diese würstchen ich glaube auf
jeden fall dass wir auf dem weg dahin
sind aber ich würde dir bei einem punkt
nicht zustimmen und zwar finde ich das
im internet haben die halt alle ihre
anonymität dass das was die sich auf der
straße mir niemals trauen würden im
gesicht mein gesicht zu sagen
schreiben sie dann im internet über mich
und das finde ich halt dann so wenn man
wenn also meine ansicht ist ich weiß
nicht wie man das am ende machen soll du
bist der deal aber ich habe das gefühl
wenn man jetzt nicht zum beispiel bei
miles oder kategorie einfach jeder wenn
er sich ein profil öffnet sein name
internet mein ich habe nichts zu
verlieren ich meinen namen kennt ja
jeder deswegen bin ich da wahrscheinlich
eh schon so ein bisschen anonymität tut
nix aber dann würden die hätten ja alle
gar nicht die cognis mehr so auf dich zu
zu gehen und dich fertig zu machen aber
manche leute müssen ja auch ihre
meinung anonym sagen weil sie sonst
vielleicht ja auch anderweitig irgendwie
verfolgt ja du und der stärkste siehst
scheißhaus sind keine meinungen
anonymität will ich auch besprechen ohne
frage aber ich würde gerne erstmal beim
groß bleiben weil du hast jetzt gerade
davon gesprochen dass das wir auf einer
auf einer richtung sind das eine gesehen
also dass die gesellschaft sich so
weiterentwickelt dass eben leute import
werden die vorher die sogenannte mitte
als minderheit fertig gemacht werden
konnten und und diana wollte da
eigentlich genau so was wie black ice
meta wäre wahrscheinlich oder wären ohne
social media nie so groß geworden und
hätte man da eben schon
das gab das facebook das alles blockiert
und gesperrt hätte am anfang hätte das
einfach eine ganze bewegung gestoppt und
deswegen dürfen diese plattform einfach
nicht zu stark reguliert werden weil der
jahren austausch und dieser umbruch
passieren muss in der passiert ja nur
wenn ganz viele meinungen aufeinander
klatschen und das eben auch zu sehr
kontroversen themen die sonst eben
vielleicht blockiert werden würden
weiter irgendwie bluetooth oder tv zu
sehen ist also ich erfahre eigentlich
jeden tag hast du ne also entweder soll
ich mal eine treppe runterfallen oder
generell einfach sterben und still sein
aber ich nutze dann auch diverse tools
und blockiere zb account oder habe auch
bestimmte worte gebäck listet die mich
sehr stark träger oder die ich einfach
nicht auf meinem account lesen möchte
und das geht ja auch aber wie machst du
das denn also ich meine du kriegst ja
auch oft genug wellen des hasses ab vor
allem von männern vor allem bei
feministischen themen so zumindest meine
beobachtung und du sagst es aber nicht
die plattform sollen das lösen sondern
die user userin selbst also ich finde
die plattform sollten und userinnen mehr
du baukasten mäßig tools an die hand
geben wie wir zum beispiel unsere
accounts es moderieren kann und so kann
man das schon stück für stück eben auch
selbst regulieren so dass es dann auch
emotional noch gut tut und noch für mich
tragbar ist aber jetzt bin ich total
unfair ich meine du hast ja den hass
nicht dahin geschrieben aber du sollst
ihn dann quasi aufräumen obwohl das gar
nicht wollte es so wahnsinnig unfair ja
weil ich kann es ja auch immer schon
stück für stück mehr automatisieren zum
beispiel durch diese blackbirds dass ich
eben gar nicht mehr lesen muss wenn
jemand so schreibt er ich weiß nichts
davon der wahrscheinlich
aber so läuft das könnte ich dann
einfach dass ich so was nie wieder lesen
muss und das ist natürlich auch schon
einschneidende sache in die
meinungsfreiheit von einer leuten aber
ich sage da halt eben das ist mein
account mein digitales wohnzimmer da
will ich so was nicht lesen macht ihr es
euch einfach zu leicht dass ihr sagt wir
brauchen eine harte hand wir brauchen
bessere gesetze elektra ich finde es ist
notwendig weil ich zum beispiel oder
auch andere von der l spielt die platz
community wir bekommen so viel hass
tagtäglich und also ich würde ich wäre
24 7 beschäftigt mit hass kommentaren
löschen deswegen fände es toll wenn das
von der plattform auch noch ausgehen
würde
wenn da einfach eine regulierung
stattfindet muss einfach sein also mir
ist es wichtig dabei zu sein um ein
statement gegen hass zu setzen weil ich
und so viele andere angefeindet werden
und das muss ich auf jeden fall ändern
was sind denn deine persönlichen
erfahrung also wenn du einen bestimmten
hass kommentar kriegst und ihn dann
meldest weiß ich an zeigt sie damit also
erst mal dauert sehr lange bis überhaupt
irgendwas passiert und dann werden
manche kommentare gelöscht
manche bleiben einfach stehen selbst
wenn man zum beispiel das wort
[ __ ] unterbindet die leute die
lassen sich mal was neues einfallen
lassen also zum beispiel da werden
trennen der regenbogen flaggen dann
gekostet images zusammengebastelt also
da wird sich mal was neues überlegt und
das finde ich erschreckend mit was für
einer energie dann dieser hater auch das
agieren kannst du das machst schon
merklich aber das klingt jetzt erstmal
recht plausibel also die mit den mitteln
die diana vorgeschlagen hat kommt
zumindest die beiden nicht so gut klar
und wollen deswegen dass die plattform
selber bisschen stärker vorgehen kann
das nachvollziehen
also ich kann das bedürfnis total
nachvollziehen ich glaube nur nicht dass
regulierung das allheilmittel ist um das
jahr aufzuheben
wie du schon gesagt hast das problem ist
der hass in der gesellschaft und gesetze
können da auch nur bedingt weiterhelfen
weil es gibt schon gesetze
mir liegt das thema am herzen weil die
meinungsfreiheit wie wir sie hier in
deutschland haben nicht
selbstverständlich ist und das durchaus
auch staaten auf der welt gibt die sich
das netz der ezb als vorbild genommen
haben um damit aber staatliche zensur zu
fördern und deswegen sollten wir auf
jeden fall über das thema
meinungsfreiheit in diesem zusammenhang
sprechen
wir haben zum beispiel das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz das hat das sind
seit drei jahren in kraft das hat
offensichtlich keine besserung gebracht
wir haben das strafgesetzbuch
morddrohung beleidigungen sind heute
schon strafbar und trotzdem passieren
sehr weiter und wir aber dann erwarte
ich bitte von experten dass sie sich was
einfallen lassen damit das besser
reguliert werden kann
also das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein
was ist denn mit der polizei was ist
denn eure erfahrung mit der habt ihr
schon mal jemanden angezeigt also mit
einer morddrohung darf man ja jemand
anzeigen und das ist eigentlich relativ
eindeutig genau was da passiert also ich
habe über zwei beginn an gezeigt also
einmal über das internet da hab ich bis
heute keine antwort und einmal war es
auf der straße wo ich angegriffen wurde
da bin ich zur polizei gegangen
da wurde sofort gehandelt also ich würde
dann auch der justiz mehr zepter oder
mehr mittel an die hand geben damit dass
alles schneller und auch besser läuft
dass das die leute besser nachverfolgt
werden können das dann auch wieder die
plattform am zug das die daten rausgeben
aber genau dass sie zusammenarbeiten und
zwar besser und da muss die plattform
auch auf die justiz zu kommen natürlich
mich würde mal interessieren was sind
eure erfahrungen habt ihr schon mal hats
kommentare abbekommen wie reagiert ihr
drauf habt ihr sie zur anzeige gebracht
habt ihr sie irgendwo gemeldet was ist
dann passiert trieb das alles was
schreibt uns gerne wieder in die
kommentare während wir hier weiter
diskutieren zum beispiel mit hans wenn
wir mal darüber reden warum hate speech
auch plattformen ich will gar nicht
sagen geduldet wird aber warum
vielleicht nicht so effizient dagegen
vorgegangen wird da kannst du uns ein
bisschen was aus dem nähkästchen
erzählen ich glaube das versprechen der
sozialen netzwerke dass alle alles sagen
dürfen
tatsächlich an der realität verprellt
gerade und wir umdenken lernen müssen
und die plattformen stil stärker in die
verantwortung gezogen werden müssen
etwas gegen hass kriminalität im netz
vorzunehmen du hast mal einen film
gemacht einen dokumentarfilm über die
klimas also so genannte content
moderatorin die vor allem auf den
philippinen sitzen und zu
hunderttausenden illegales zeug
pornografie rassismus aus dem netz
löschen sollen gegen einen hungerlohn
warum glaubst du bringt wir haben die
plattform gar kein interesse daran so
stark da vorzugehen
also worüber wir noch gar nicht
gesprochen haben in der diskussion ist
ja die sozialen netzwerke haben ganz
bestimmte infrastruktur und diese
infrastruktur befördert das sensations-
getriebene inhalte starke äußerungen
verkürzte nachrichten er mit lob mit
likes mit views belohnt werden und ich
glaube das ist etwas was man beachten
muss weil - führen auch die digitale
welt mit der analogen welt getrennt und
gar nicht in einen zusammenhang gebracht
und ich glaube schon dass unser
verhalten was wir erlernen durch den
umgang mit den sozialen medien weil wir
wissen wie sie funktionieren wir wissen
wie reagieren darauf wir sind wie hunde
die sozusagen auch bestimmte krieger
knöpfe anstoßen um erfolg zu haben
die machen etwas mit unserem verhalten
sie verstärken und hast die verstärkten
hetze die verstärken sensations-
getriebenes und ich glaube da muss man
tatsächlich darüber reden und in dieser
form auch mal regulieren zu sagen wie
kann eigentlich so eine infrastruktur
völlig anders ablaufen sie können
vielleicht inhalte belohnt werden die
differenziert sind die komplex sind die
bestimmte argumente vorlegen und nicht
verkürzte falschmeldung und da gibt es
noch ein großes einen großen
nachholbedarf und in dieser
stellschraube finde ich kann man schon
die verantwortung den sozialen medien
übertragen da etwas zu tun und danach zu
denken also ich stimme dir absolut zu
und möchte noch dazu sagen dass ich
nicht die analoge und digitale welt
trainer ganz im gegenteil ich habe ja
gesagt wir haben eine gesellschaft mit
hass und eine gesellschaft auf facebook
die probleme trenne ich aber nicht dass
jetzt die gesellschaft nicht analog wäre
deswegen bin ich auch dafür diese ganzen
dinge sowieso einzustampfen
das heißt wir es in teilen zu denn nicht
weil dann könnte wenn die dvd mehr wenn
wir sagen wir machen die dinger dicht er
will sie zumindest mal reformieren das
ist gehen wir mal so weil wir dann nicht
okay du bist wenn es diese gesetze schon
gibt aber sie offenbar nicht richtig
durchgesetzt werden dann müssen wir
vielleicht die plattformen dazu zwingen
dass sie ihre gesetze besser durchsetzen
also mit höheren strafen mit mit dingen
die ihnen richtig wehtun
und das ist auch das haben wir schon
also das netz die ezb sieht hohe
bußgelder millionenbereich vor und wir
haben schon straftatbestände wir haben
diese gesetze das was aber jetzt
passiert ist dass der gesetzgeber oder
der staat quasi es den sozialen
netzwerken überlässt inhalte zu löschen
und zwar nach ihren communitys anders
und zwar nicht nach dem gesetz
also es gibt ganz wenige fälle wie
tatsächlich nach dem netz den gemeldet
worden sind und da ist überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehbar auf welcher basis werde
es entscheidet mit welchen algorithmen
etc das heißt wenn wir über
regulierungen sprechen dann dann bin ich
nicht dafür jetzt irgendwie neuen
straftatbestand zu erfinden sondern eben
für mehr transparenz zu sorgen
mehr transparenz ist ja auch eine deiner
forderung was die klarnamen pflicht
anbelangt warum glaubst du dass die
anonymität ein wichtiges problem ist bei
der hitze pietsch also vor allem in
unserer generation und ich bin halt
nicht wie du ich bin direkt mit dem
internet aufgewachsen und viele
generation unter uns die werden halt
komplett mit dem scheiß wenn ich jetzt
einfach mal sagen aufwachsen und da ist
gang und gäbe dass jeder fünf bis sechs
säcke konz hat wenn ich so meine
schwester und ihre kleinen freunde
angucke die haben alle ihre fake
accounts auf denen die dann so nebenbei
andere leute hätten und ich bin der
ansicht wenn du jetzt weil ich bin ja
ähnlich anonym im internet also ich hab
da überhaupt nichts zu verlieren mich
stört es auch nicht ich denke immer so
okay wenn du so krass anonym sein willst
was hast du davor diese eine konnte kann
mich jetzt beleidigen der kann sich
löschen und dann direkte dessen account
öffnen und damit weitermachen und das
ist halt das hat mich auf du hast mach
jetzt schön nach hinten getrieben bei es
intensiv nach hinten gelaufen als die
klarnamen pflicht ins spiel gebracht das
kann ich will ja nicht dass er hier die
sehen können sondern dass dann am ende
direkt finden karlsons kurs meyer
dann hast du ja also ich finde die
klarnamen schlechtesten ganz schlechte
idee anonymität ist ein teil der
meinungsfreiheit
und auch ein ganz wichtiger da geht es
auch ein bisschen weiter als nur um
deutschland es gibt länder da ist
anonymität nicht dazu da um zu hetzen
sondern eine form des schutzes vor
staatlichen repressionen und wir müssen
noch nicht mal so weit gehen also in
deutschland whistleblowing wäre nicht
möglich wenn es keine anonymität im netz
gibt leute möchten vielleicht über
unternehmen in denen sie arbeiten und
über missstände berichten all das ist
nicht möglich wenn wir nicht auch die
möglichkeit haben anonym im netz
unterwegs zu sein also aus
datenschutzrechtlicher sicht finde ich
immer ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen
ganz schlechtes argument weil wenn wir
da nachgeben würden dann haben die
meisten menschen nichts zu verbergen
zumindest im strafrechtlichen sinne aber
das kann nicht direkt bedeuten dass
quasi jeder verpflichtet sein muss sich
mit seinen daten zu öffnen also hast du
gerade über auch ausland gesprochen du
hast dir selber erfahrung mit mit
familie in syrien inwiefern also ich
habe familie die aus syrien kommt und
syrien wie viele andere länder auf der
welt ist ein land in dem die menschen
nicht mit denselben privilegien und
demokratischen grundsätzen leben können
und in solchen ländern spielt natürlich
anonymität eine ganz wichtige rolle auch
um sachen sagen zu können also
tatsächlich auch um aktiv seine meinung
zu äußern weil es eben anders gar nicht
möglich ist
du musst aber nicht nach syrien danach
bitte ich möchte dass also wirklich aus
eigener erfahrung in meiner altersklasse
gab es dann einige die waren halt schwul
oder lesbisch oder irgendwie nicht
normgerecht sexuell ja das geht
das ist ja sehr eng definiert und für
die war das eine große große
erleichterung in dieses internet gehen
zu können anonym dort mit anderen leuten
in austausch zu treten
perspektiven identitäten von sich selber
auszuprobieren und sich selber zu finden
was alle diese jugendlichen irgendwie
das mussten wir alle mal machen ja und
das war für alle hart und anonymität
weiter enorm gut bei du bist jetzt
soweit nach
wie heißt du hast deine meinung jetzt
geändert in diesem punkt das für junge
leute und so weil da war das internet
hat genau das was er gesagt hat so das
war das erste mal dass ich in den ort
gefunden hat an dem ich nicht alleine
war wichtig wie ein alien gefühlt habe
und unter leuten auf einmal gecheckt
habe okay du bist ganz normal wie du
bist oder so in dem punkt bin ich da
komplett bei ihm aber das hat nichts mit
uns zu tun
na ja aber du kannst nämlich sagen
anonymität ja wie tief das aber würde
ein mittlerer zerreißprobe büßten jahr
also bei den klarnamen stimme ich
wirklich der anderen seite muss ich
sagen
pseudonyme können von mir aus
weiterbestehen gar kein problem aber wie
wäre es denn wenn die daten dann
wirklich im hintergrund gespeichert sind
und die justiz kann die abrufen und auch
ohne 10.000 umwege sondern ziemlich
schnell dass dann auch die sozialen
medien natürlich den schritt
ich glaube so einfach ist das nicht
schön gemein erklärung square uns auf
ip-adressen und also das ist ja genau
die frage wie würde man sowas eigentlich
technisch umsetzen muss jetzt jeder zu
irgendeiner stelle gehen und seinen
ausweis vorzeigen bevor er sich bei
facebook an wenn will also die daten die
jetzt schon abgerufen werden können sind
natürlich keine ausweisdaten aber zum
beispiel die ip-adresse und ähnliches
und damit können die
strafverfolgungsbehörden ja auch schon
viel machen
und wie gesagt diese möglichkeiten gibt
es schon also dass die klarnamen pflicht
keine lösung ist glaube ich sind wir uns
fast alle einig hier finden alle schon
vorne ich glaube was was überhaupt gar
keine lösung ist für das problem
ich spüre von eurer seite so diesen
impuls in nicht nachvollziehen kann der
ist aber so historisch das internet ist
mal so auf gekommen und hat die leute
emanzipiert hat sozusagen allen ein
sprachrohr verliehen facebook hat das
jahrelang gesagt gibt allen menschen
eine stimme alles mit allen zu teilen
und jetzt müssen wir für den reality
check machen und die realität hat dieses
statement eingeholt es gibt eine
gespaltene gesellschaft hat es gibt hat
die online hetze geht in das analoge
leben und wir können nicht so tun als
wäre das nicht da wir müssen da
regulieren wir müssen da eingreift wir
müssen die sozialen netzwerke in die
verantwortung ziehen genau dieses
problem anzugehen
und da findet viel viel zu wenig statt
die content motorrad das sind überlastet
die politik die gesetze sind da ja aber
sie wären nicht umgesetzt die wir nicht
durchgeführt also da muss man doch was
machen da kann man nicht sagen
schon ein bisschen drüber und hoffen
dass das irgendwann weg ist das ist er
muss man weiß nicht genau was trägst du
vor was konkret man muss facebook hat
oder magdeburg hat vor zwei jahren
veröffentlich 2009/10 3,7 milliarden
euro für die sicherheit der plattform
ausgibt das klingt jetzt erst mal sehr
viel aber der jahresumsatz dieser firma
70 milliarden euro
das heißt ja macht ein bisschen mehr als
fünf prozent investiert er dafür dass
die user und userinnen sicher sind sie
könnten vielmehr moderationsteam sign
stellen die viel besser ausgebildet sind
die vielmehr ein rechtskenntnis haben
was ist überhaupt hate speech das eine
unglaublich schwierige entscheidung die
müssen die im sekundentakt treffen
irgendwo auf der welt die vielleicht gar
nicht den kulturellen kontext dieser
debatte wissen da muss investieren da
muss man den sozialen netzwerken sagen
ihr macht viel viel zu wenig investiert
und dann muss man auch mit gesetzen ran
und sagen wenn ihr das nicht macht dann
fliegt er aus dem markt raus dann wird
das hier abgestellt und dann reagieren
sie auch ich verstehe was du meinst es
ist eben nicht genug
es muss eben noch viel mehr passieren
die frage ist nur wer sollte da ist dann
entscheiden sollte das ist es nicht so
dass wir die ganze verantwortung
privaten firmen übergeben einer handvoll
leuten im silicon valley die über die
digitale meinungsfreiheit entscheiden
ich wäre gern dabei gewesen in mit einer
kamera in dem raum wo darüber debattiert
wird soll dann donald trump gesperrt
werden und nicht das sind private
unternehmen die das machen was wäre denn
diana wer du mit deinen vielen vielen
followern sagen würde basta auf facebook
und instagram ihr erhaltet die regel
nicht ein ich bin dann mal weg wäre das
mit drohkulisse naja wenn ihr euch
zusammen schließt sagen wir mal keine
ahnung 20 reichweitenstärksten accounts
in deutschland würden sagen ganz ehrlich
aber kein bock mehr drauf machen nicht
mehr mit ich glaube die plattform nehmen
das auch schon war das immer mehr
konkurrenz kommt es gibt einfach
verschiedene plattformen angeboten über
nutzen kann die einen dann vielleicht
mehr oder weniger zu sagen also ich muß
wenn jetzt nicht abhängig nur von
facebook zum beispiel bei instagram höre
ich da raus du planst nicht den boykott
diverser plattform nähe dass er nicht
also ich bin auch zum thema anonymität
zum beispiel für mich war es einfach
damals eine neue welt die sich mehr
eröffnet hat ich komme aus einem kleinen
dorf und ohne das internet
hätte ich so viel nicht gelernt und so
viele chancen einfach nicht gehabt und
ich merke das aber eben jetzt ja auch
dass so viele sachen dann doch mancher
schon für mich zu sehr reguliert werden
obwohl wir dann auch in deutschland sind
und ich sehe ganz ihm wissen wie das an
den anderen ländern ist wo man wirklich
richtig angst um sein leben haben muss
wenn man da irgendwelche dinge postet
als ich post ja auch manchem politischen
content habe zum beispiel auch schon
öfters über die lage der uiguren
gepostet und ich will gar nicht wissen
wie das ist wenn ich jetzt nach china
reisen würde wenn die diese ganzen
videos sehen und das irgendwie mit mir
verknüpfen würden also hätte schon jetzt
ein bisschen angst auch bei ist eben
nicht so demokratisch da ist wie bei uns
aktuell
ich finde schon dass man sich auch über
alternative druckmittel gedanken machen
müsste oder eben auch generell über das
thema hast in der gesellschaft also es
gibt glaube ich bundesweit eine
organisation die sich wirklich um
betroffene kümmert und die bei zum
beispiel gerichtsprozessen unterstützt
also hält
da frage ich mich warum also da ist noch
so viel drin da ist nur da gibt es noch
so viele möglichkeiten auch irgendwie
solidarität zu organisieren was ja auch
schon passiert bevor man direkt nach dem
gesetzgeber ruft ich bin mal gespannt
was ihr davon haltet sollen wir facebook
zerschlagen sollen wir youtube die
plattform auf der ich vielleicht gerade
zu schauen einfach abschaffen würde das
probleme lösen wenn wir eine neue
plattform schaffen natürlich wir wollen
ja weiter digital diskutieren eure
meinung ist natürlich sehr wichtig und
wenn ja wie sehr denn so ein neues
mögliches netzwerk aus der kompromiss
soll es darum gehen ob es möglicherweise
vorschläge gibt die euch dann ausdenken
könnte in ihren jeweiligen gruppen um
die andere seite zu euch zu nutzen
ich gehe mal davon aus dass die
klarnamen pflicht keine rolle spielen
wird bei den kompromissen also mein
kompromiss vorschlag ist die ressourcen
bei der polizei müssen ausgebaut werden
wir fordern deshalb mehr schulungen
bessere ansprechpartner innen in allen
bundesländern möglicherweise sogar eine
einheitlichkeit dass man als user und
userinnen möglichst sicher sein kann
dass sie jemand kompetentes diesen fall
in die hand nimmt
auf jeden fall
gut es war jetzt auch der leichter
kompromiss muss man auch sagen wie schön
dass ihr dazu gekommen sei so jetzt habt
ihr sagen wir mal eine minute zeit zu
überlegen ob ihr die anderen irgendwie
überzeugen können merkt euch ihre plätze
und los geht's so wären jetzt hier gelb
und grün miteinander debattieren was ein
möglicher kompromiss vorschlag ist geht
natürlich die frage auch an euch
vielleicht habt ihr ja eine idee was
könnte helfen gegen hass rede im
internet wenn man vielleicht nicht ganz
so viel regulieren will oder vielleicht
ein bisschen regulieren vielleicht habt
ihr ja auch normal
dazu schreibt uns bitte in die
kommentare
die zeit läuft leicht ab sehr gespannt
ob wir noch näher zusammen
also mein kompromiss fahrzeugs
eingeschlagen wie eine bombe
wollt ihr anfangen habt ihr auch ein
vorschlag an die andere gruppe zum
beispiel hatten der auf jeden fall
darüber gesprochen dass es eine option
geben könnte fake profile mehr zu
blockieren oder einzuschränken weil er
wahrscheinlich kennen viele von euch das
ja auch dass leute eben kein profil bild
haben die folgen irgendwie gar keinen
leuten sind wir aber gar nicht aktiv
sondern die haben nur ein account um zu
hassen und die kann man relativ schnell
an verschiedenen faktoren ausfindig
machen und da könnte man zum beispiel
die plattform viel mehr in die
verantwortung ziehen dass er ihm schon
mal eine möglichkeit um viel hass der
passiert ja einzuschränken
also der vorschlag ist wir gehen nicht
gegen anonyme profile vor sondern wir
gehen explizit gegen fake profile vor
stimmt ihr zu ist das ein weg wo er sagt
ja dass oder
ich habe auch sehr viel zeit von leuten
die ihre gesichter einfach stehen haben
und auch ihr business markiert habe und
so also du glaubst also ist wirklich so
der bringt nicht viel
du hast du nicht die serie doch das
problem ist die leute dann sofort neuen
account aufmachen können die haben
bestimmt ein gewisses spielzeit ist er
wieder gesperrt wird in der zeit kann
wieder schön hätten und nur zu löschen
genauso wie kommentare löschen geht
nämlich gesagt auch nicht weit genug
also ich möchte dann wenn es wirklich
krasse hass kommentare sind dass es da
noch zur anzeige gebracht wird und das
passiert ja in dem fall dann auch nicht
okay aber es ist wahr ein
kompromissvorschlag ihr müsst ja nicht
darauf eingehen ihr seid auch nicht
darauf ein gewinn habt ihr ein
vielleicht geht ja die gegenseite auf
euren zu den formulieren
ja es gibt so mehrere kleinere ich zum
beispiel sagen es ist total wichtig dass
es eine beschwerdestelle gibt bei den
netzwerken wo man wenn man sich beim zu
unrecht gelöscht führt melden kann
das gibt es überhaupt man kriegt
überhaupt keine antworten wie die
kriterien ausgefallen sind warum etwas
gelöscht wurde
das finde ich ganz wichtig weil es in
den transparenten einblick gibt genauso
müssen die sozialen netzwerke einen
transparenzbericht abgeben jedes jahr da
geht mir war auch nicht zu weit sondern
im grunde müssen sie nicht nur die
anzahl der accounts oder profile diese
gelöscht haben veröffentlichen sondern
auch warum
und das wären extrem demokratischer
einblick für uns das wir diskutieren
können darüber hey da wurde was gelöscht
das ist nicht okay oder da wurde viel zu
wenig gelöscht was hätte gelöscht werden
müssen und es heißt du überlegst vor
eine verschärfung der transparenzregeln
für netze jahre stimmt ihr zu dass sie
nach vorne gehen zumindest teilen
wahrscheinlich findet den eindruck den
du hast dass die transparenz bei
sozialen netzwerken sehr klein
geschrieben und ja absolut ich finde
genau solche debatten räume fehlen
eigentlich in unserer gesellschaft weil
das thema wie wir mit hass und hetze im
netz umgehen hat eigentlich eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche debatte
hervorgerufen wie wegen wir freiheit und
sicherheit miteinander ab und finde das
ist eine total interessantes
spannungsfeld was ist eigentlich viel
öfter diskutiert werden muss ich fand
die debatte wirklich super also
konstruktiv alles wir uns nicht
gestritten und ich war ein im grunde
genommen sind wir alle einer meinung wir
wollen alle dass der hass im internet
weniger wird jetzt hat er noch die frage
wie
symbol gesetze erlässt einfach nur weil
wahlkampf ist sondern sich vielmehr
immer auf den ausbau der strukturen die
dazu dienen können hass im netz zu
bekämpfen konzentriert und vielleicht
auch ein weiteres angebot schafft für
betroffene an dass sie sich wenden
können um geben in so einem fall hilfe
zu besorgen also die als
zivilgesellschaft sollten definitiv
eingreifen wenn wir sehen dass da
irgendwer von hass beleidigt was
betroffen ist es ja ich finde das ist
zivilcourage einfach nur genauso wie
wenn jetzt draußen auf der straße
irgendwie angegriffen wird und das finde
ich es so eine sache die wir alle machen
können damit es uns allen besser geht
ich würde dem zustimmen und einfach nur
ergänzen wenn es deine freundinnen
betrifft stehe ihnen bei und wenn es
deine freunde oder freundinnen machen
dann hilft den so die brauchen irgendwie
irgendwann im leben und das ist genauso
zivilcourage den eigenen freundinnen und
freunden halt mal zu sagen das auch so
oder so nicht machen und vielleicht
vielleicht gehen wir mal gemeinsam
irgendwo hin wo die vielleicht geholfen
werden kann
wir sind ziemlich nah aneinander
rangekommen
fast alle haben so einen halben fuß von
hier im sogenannten kompromiss feld
gehabt ich danke euch sehr dafür es
waren glaube ich wahnsinnig viele
perspektiven die wir eingenommen haben
und es wurde ja sogar innerhalb des
spiels manche leute von dingen von einer
gegenmeinung überzeugt genau darum geht
es bei 310 fragen ganz herzlichen dank
dafür
super
das war ja mal wieder eine folge oder
also bei diesem thema bleibt es einfach
tricky sehr interessant fand ich
allerdings die idee alle social media
konzerne einfach zu zerschlagen was
meint ihr
wenn euch 13 fragen gefällt dann könnt
ihr sehr eindeutig sein und hier unseren
kanal abonnieren hier findet ihr eine
weitere folge und hier gibt es ein
weiteres video zum thema vielen dank
[Musik]